welcome back okay so we've been talking
about data-driven modeling and control
of complex systems maybe high
dimensional maybe nonlinear and we've
been essentially building this diagram
where we have some system we have some
controller the system has measurements
so there's some measurements of the
system Y and then the control determines
some kind of a feedback signal to affect
some actuators you to modify the system
behavior for some desired objective okay
now remember the system generally we
don't have the equations of motion given
to us this is not like you open a
textbook and you have the equations of
motion to then design a control law so
we're talking about how do we discover
the system model from data okay and in
the past we've talked about balanced
model reduction and system
identification where you have some
inputs you some outputs Y and you try to
get a reduced order model of the
input-output dynamics what we're going
to talk about now is slightly different
but very related where in this case
we're assuming that we have access to
full state measurements so our
measurements Y is the or the entire
state of the system that might be high
dimensional that might be low
dimensional but we're going to assume
that we don't have limited measurements
we can actually measure the full system
so this is becoming increasingly
important kind of in this age of big
data where it is increasingly likely
that you might actually have some
scenarios where you have full state
measurements of your system ok so what
we're going to say is we're going to
call this system identification system
ID with full state measurements and of
course the goal here is for control so
we don't just want to identify a model
of the system we want to model we want a
model of the input-output dynamics of
the system so that we can then design a
control law okay so our system model
would generally be given by some kind of
X dot equals f of X comma U so there's
some nonlinear dynamics X dot equals f
of X but we also have to take into
account what the effect of the actuation
you
is we assume that we can measure that
full state X and so we're going to use
data science and data-driven
optimization things like machine
learning to build models of the system
that we can then use for control and
what I would advocate in this case is
something like a model predictive
controller so here M PC equals model
predictive control which is a very very
powerful control optimization framework
where if you have a model for your
system you can essentially run a bunch
of forecasts of that model for different
actuation and puts you and then you can
optimize over that you for some kind of
a short time control signal that will
maximize an objective function okay so
model predictive control is very
powerful you can use it for nonlinear
control and so I would definitely
recommend you know looking into into MPC
but the basic idea is we're going to
talk about how do we build system ID
models of these possibly nonlinear
input-output dynamics that we could then
use with model predictive control and
the the difference here with between
what we're doing now and what we were
doing with the balanced model reduction
and system identification is that here
and we're explicit explicitly assuming
that we have full state measurements y
equals x ok so this is closely related
to things like balance truncation
balance p OD I consistent realization
algorithm but more specifically for kind
of the big data limit of full state
measurements okay and one of the key
tools that we're going to use throughout
all of this is data-driven regression
and that's maybe that sounds a little
fancy I guess all I mean is we're gonna
use linear regression but we're going to
do we're gonna do linear regression of
data onto these models so we're gonna
fit model parameters using data and
we're going to add some regularizing
terms to that linear regression for
example to promote sparsity so there
might be only a few terms in this model
or to prevent overfitting okay so so
we'll use modern regression methods to
find these models from data and I want
to walk you
you're just kind of so this is the
overview I want to walk you through what
we're going to be looking at in the next
few lectures okay so in the simplest
case we might have linear dynamics okay
we might have linear dynamics and in the
case of linear dynamics we might just
write down X dot equals ax
okay these would be the unforced
dynamics of the system with no u we
could just build a model X dot equals ax
this would be the dynamic mode
decomposition so DMD and there will be
video lectures on the DMD method and all
of the methods I'm telling you about
here okay but what we're going to do in
the case of system ID with full state
measurements let's say for control this
is very important we're not just doing
unforced system identification we're
doing system identification so that we
can modify the system with control so in
that case what we're going to do is not
just use regression to build a model of
this dynamical system a we're also going
to figure out how the inputs affect that
system so we're also going to identify
this plus bu term and that's going to be
called dynamic mode decomposition with
control so I mean add a little C there
okay so a pretty straightforward
modification to dynamic mode
decomposition allows us to also build a
linear model of the of how the input
effects that state okay in the case of a
nonlinear system there are a number of
emerging techniques to identify the
full-blown nonlinear system X dot equals
f of X so X dot equals f of X if I just
had X dot equals f of X essentially what
I would do is is do something like the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics sparse identification of
nonlinear dynamics this is the Sindhi
algorithm I'll put a link to this in the
comments but essentially what this does
is it builds a library of all of the
possible right-hand-side functions that
this could that could describe the
dynamics and it uses sparse regression
to select only the fewest nonlinear
terms on the right hand side that agree
with X dot equals those terms
okay so it essentially sets up a sparse
regression to identify the nonlinear
terms in a dynamical system it is that
that sparsity promoting constraint
regularizes the problem and prevents
overfitting and it also gives you an
interpretable model so it only has a few
terms so that you can interpret what the
nonlinear dynamics of that system are so
this is kind of a neat data driven
regression method for a nonlinear system
and I'll talk about how we can also
identify what the effective control is
and that'll be called Cindy with control
okay so hopefully you're seeing kind of
a theme here we're gonna take the
dynamic mode decomposition algorithm and
add control we're gonna take the Cindy
algorithm and add control and then we're
going to show how you can put these into
a model pretty good predictive control
framework once you have these these
models these States based models okay
and then the last leg of this I want to
talk about is if I have a nonlinear
system but I want a linear
representation of a nonlinear system
okay so I'll tell you what that means so
if I want a linear representation of a
nonlinear system then there is this
Koopman operator theory so I have you
might have seen some of these talks or
papers or lectures about the Koopman
operator where essentially what I can do
is I could take this this measurement X
and I could actually enrich it into an
even larger measurement I could measure
things like x squared and x cubed and X
to the fourth and so on and so forth
and in that space of all possible
measurements of my system it turns out
that the dynamics actually become linear
okay even for strongly nonlinear
dynamics so what we're going to say is
that if I have a rich enough measurement
Y if Y is even bigger than the state if
it's like all of the possible
measurements I could take of the state
then I can have this Y dot equals this
big Koopman operator K times y where
this is actually a linear representation
of these nonlinear dynamics and the
catch is that this measurement function
Y has to be sufficiently rich that this
Koopman operator
fury holds okay so we have Koopman in
general finding these measurements so
that you get this approximate linear
representation can be pretty challenging
and we'll talk about how you can do that
how you can find good measurements of
your systems so that they even non
linear systems look linear and then what
we're going to talk about is how do we
add control okay and I'm being a little
vague about how we add control here
because it's a little bit more subtle so
Koopman with control okay so this is
basically the overview of what we're
gonna do over the next few lectures
we're going to do system identification
both linear and nonlinear system ID for
systems where we assume we have full
state measurements but we want to do
control so we have full state
measurements and some input U we want to
build these these system models from
data using regression and then we're
going to use these for control for
example using model predictive control
okay so this is all coming up this is
going to build on some other lectures
some related lectures on dynamical
systems kind of Cindy d-md Cindy and
Koopman is a separate lecture series
I'll point you to
but then what we're going to talk about
now is how to modify them to add add
control okay thank you